Okay,
I'd like to begin welcome back.
It is good to see you all.
Uh,
if a bit startling.
I don't know where those two weeks went.
Um,
so tell me,
I asked you to read blood Meridian over break.
Um,
was this a happy spring break task for you?
Was it good beach reading as I promised?
No,
no.
Um,
I'd like,
before I begin my lecture today just to hear a little bit from you,
just so that I know what you're thinking about as I,
as I talked to you about this book,
um,
who liked this novel.
Okay,
good.
Maybe a half of you.
Um,
someone tell me why they liked it.
Someone,
someone somewhere.
Tell me why they liked it.
Okay.
Now you're getting all quiet.
Tell cause someone can,
can tell me one sentence why you like this novel.
Yes,
thank you.
Judges.
You like how creepy the judges.
It is impressive how creepy he is.
Yes.
Okay,
why else?
Yes,
I should like how quickly some of the atrocities happening in this passage where
it is [inaudible]
and you liked that.
That was good.
Yeah,
it certainly is a kind of virtuosic a representation of violence.
Yes,
absolutely.
What did it remind you of?
Well,
yes.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
The ending is very strange and we'll talk about that.
Well,
we'll talk about that.
What else?
Yes,
I liked it.
It read like a nightmare.
What does that
me taking it.
It felt like a magnum.
Jerry's sort of jumble.
Then you can very sensory.
Yeah.
It is very sensory.
You know,
this prose concentrate so much on the material of the world.
Absolutely.
And it does have that,
um,
feeling of drawing you into its world very completely.
I think also that sense of nightmarish snus is heightened by the fact that the
plot is not very strong in this novel.
That's not what's driving this novel.
You're laughing.
Why do you laugh?
What is,
why do you laugh
about that?
About the plot?
Yes.
You're still smiling from the laughter.
So I'm gonna ask you,
um,
just because like,
yes,
that is true,
that part of the reason that I found it difficult to continue reading.
Uh Huh.
You know,
just maybe you'd be interested by the,
I guess the drive,
sort of emotionless way of presenting violence.
Do you know,
it's sort of interesting,
but the fact that there wasn't,
they didn't seem to be like a point or like a place that they're going,
it made it really hard to not just like be like,
oh,
this is going to be disgusting.
Like switch.
Yeah,
it does.
It can,
it can produce this,
this aversion in the,
in readers.
How many had,
were averse to this novelty?
Okay.
A few of you at least.
Yeah.
I think when I first tried to read this novel,
I failed twice.
I'm a sensitive soul.
Um,
so I failed twice to read this novel because of its violence and then I
persevered.
But it can get actually kind of boring sometimes I think because of the plot.
Lessness so unless you're really interested in how the story's being told in
that language,
it can be repetitive and,
and can numb you as a reader.
I think these are all aspects of the novel that I will try to account for over
the course of my two lectures.
Uh,
today and on Wednesday.
Um,
there are two other things I'm going to do in these two lectures.
One is today to think hard about what it means to track illusions in a novel.
So that's going to be one thing that I do today.
I Ellucian's appear in most of the things that we read.
Dare I say all of them,
but one never quite knows what to do with them once you have identified them.
Now,
the sense of literature as an art with a history depends on our being able to do
something without allusions or to have something to say about them.
What does it mean that one novel speaks to a,
a novel or a poem or another kind of writing from the past?
How are we to make sense of that in the evolution of the art form?
This is a foundation of what English literary study looks like pretty much at
any university,
at any university.
If you're an English major,
you're asked to study a historical range of texts.
You're asked to master in some portion or to some extent,
the literary tradition in English.
What does it mean that we're asked to do that?
Mccarthy Cormac Mccarthy's novel gives us the opportunity to take a case study.
What does it mean in this day,
in this time for this writer to be writing in a tradition.
So I'll,
illusion is one thing I'll focus on that's of general interest in literary
studies.
The second thing in the second lecture that I will focus on is what to do with
detail,
what to do with that odd detail that you notice in the novel.
It could be anything.
Is there a way of making an argument that will radiate out from that detail into
some more holistic understanding of a novel?
My second lecture,
it will a demonstration of that and an argument for that as a literary technique
and I hope that this will be useful to you in writing the next paper,
which will be coming up fairly shortly.
So I want to begin then with this quotation from Cormac McCarthy.
This was his first interview,
1992.
Um,
many of you probably know,
he's gotten a lot,
a lot more press since Oprah's book club.
Chose his latest novel the road.
Um,
he's,
he's sort of been out and about.
He gave her an interview.
Uh,
he's given an interview,
uh,
since then for a magazine before that.
He was a very reclusive writer and he had been writing since the late sixties
and by 1992 up until that point,
he had refused all interviews.
He usually refused readings even when he had zero money.
He lived out of hotel rooms.
Uh,
even when he was married and had a son,
uh,
when he was a young man,
he's on his third marriage now.
Um,
he would,
he would turn down invitations to read even when they were down to like their
last dollar.
His Ex wife tells some amusing stories about this.
Uh,
they'd,
he'd get an invitation to read.
He turned it down and they'd eat beans for another night.
So that's her,
her take on what that life was like.
Um,
he says in this interview,
the ugly fact is books are made out of books.
The novel depends for its life on the novels that have been written.
So this is my invitation to take seriously illusion in blood meridian.
Did anybody,
uh,
on their own recognize some of the sources of blood meridian?
Did you notice any illusions?
Yes.
Uh Huh.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
The oral tradition is very powerful and McCarthy's writing the sound of the
prose is very important to him.
Yeah.
What else?
Yes.
Coming up,
we're going down.
There's a lot of value with the Odyssey.
Yeah.
A lot of that cosmic imagery.
I think he does take from the great epics of our language.
Yes.
What else?
What else did you notice?
Yeah,
yeah,
absolutely.
The Bible is peppered throughout this and I'm going to have a lot to say about
that,
uh,
some to say about it today,
but I have a whole argument about that,
that I'll get to on Wednesday.
Yeah,
absolutely.
What else?
Anything else you noticed?
Well,
I'm going to start actually a little bit more,
uh,
a little bit closer to home in the American tradition.
I'm going to start with Moby Dick.
This is my lineup of texts that I'm going to use today to talk about blood
Meridian.
So I want to start with Moby Dick.
This is probably the single most important book for Mccarthy beside the Bible as
a source for both language,
uh,
character ideas,
moral questions,
all kinds of things come from Moby Dick.
And if you want to begin in the,
in the easiest way,
the first thing is to think about a hub.
A hub is known for his motto,
Maniacal Evil,
his evil quest to take on the white whale
as a character who is loquacious,
charismatic,
threatening,
violent.
He's very much a model for judge Holden.
So in that simple,
general way,
McCarthy owes a debt to Moby Dick.
There are many specific ways that this novel,
Oh,
is a debt,
um,
to Moby Dick.
One that I'll just point out is from the prophet chapter in Moby Dick.
That's chapter 19.
If you've read the novel,
uh,
you can recall that before ish my l and quick wig get on the p Quad.
They are accosted by a beggar in the street and his name is Elijah.
And he warns them and very cryptic language about what they've actually signed
away when they signed the papers to board the p Quad and he suggested what
they've signed away,
his,
their souls,
not just the couple of years of their life.
The version that we get in blood Meridian,
uh,
can be found on page 40 and 41
so he starts on 39.
Okay.
The kid has joined up with captain white's gang of filibusters and they are in a
bar
and there are,
they find this is on 39 and old disordered Mennonite in this place.
And he turns to study them,
a thin man in the leather West Kit,
a black and straight brim hat set,
square on his head,
a thin rim of whiskers.
And if you look at the Moby Dick version,
I just want to point out how closely he's following the cues here.
We kept Craig and I had just left the p Quad and we're sauntering away from the
water for the moment,
each occupied with his own thoughts.
When above the word,
the above words,
uh,
were put to us by a stranger.
This is shipmates.
Have you shipped in that ship,
uh,
put to us by a stranger who pausing before us leveled his massive finger at the
vessel in question he was,
but shabbily appareled in faded jacket and patch trousers or rag of black
handkerchief investing his neck.
Just the way that description,
the very brief description of his outfit,
what he's wearing around his neck,
his hat,
they match up in these two little paragraphs.
The Mennonite,
however,
is much more dire,
much less playful than uh,
then Melville's uh,
Alijah he says to the,
uh,
to the assembled,
man.
Okay,
they'll Jlu to a man.
This is on 40.
Who Will the United States army general worth the hell.
They will pray that they will.
He looks at his comrades.
He leans toward the Mennonite.
What does that mean old man?
Do he cross that river with Yon Filibuster armed.
You'll not cross it back.
Don't aim to cross it back.
We go into Sonora.
What's it to you?
Old Man.
The Mennonite watches the in shadow dark before them as it is reflected to him
in the mirror over the bar.
He turns to them.
His eyes are wet.
He speaks slowly.
The wrath of God lies sleeping.
It was hit a million years before man were,
and only men have the power to wake it.
Hell ain't half full here.
Me,
you carry war of a madman's making into a foreign land.
You awake more than the dogs.
But they berated the old man and swore at him until he moved off down the bar
muttering and how else could it be,
how these things end in confusion and curses and blood.
They drank on and the wind blew in the streets and the stars that had been
overhead lay low in the west.
And these young men fell afoul of others.
And words were said that could not be put right again.
And in the Dawn,
the kid and the second corporal knelt over the boy from Missouri who had been
named Earl,
and they spoke his name,
but he never spoke back.
He lay on his side and the dust of the courtyard,
the men were gone.
The whores are gone and old man's swept the clay floor within the Cantina.
The boy lay with his skull broken in a pool of blood.
None knew by whom.
A third one came to be with them in the courtyard.
It was the Mennonite,
a warm wind was blowing in the east hell.
The gray light,
the fouls roosting along the grape vines had begun to stir and call.
There is no such joy in the tavern is Baja as upon the road there too,
said the Mennonite.
He had been holding his hat in his hands and now he set it upon his head again
and turned and went out the gate.
He offers them these poor tentious sayings like this last little epigram about,
uh,
the tavern and the road there too.
And he uses this archaic language.
Yeah.
Moby Dick's Mennonite,
I mean Moby Dick's prophet who occupies the same structural spot.
A costing the main characters as they go out on their journey is much more
playful.
He is,
ah,
berated by Ishmael for pretending to have a big secret for speaking as if he had
a secret to tell but not telling it.
So McCarthy takes the model and transforms it slightly,
brings it into a realm where sincerity and depth and fear
replace the inklings of fear around a core of goodwill,
irony,
playfulness.
The reason there's that difference I think is that McCarthy has decided not to
give us an Ishmael.
Ishmael is an incredibly charming narrator.
He is thoughtful.
He's funny.
He is a little self mocking.
He can wax,
uh,
both grand and silly.
He can recognize his own silliness.
There's a vast interior of Ishmael's mind that we see in this narrative.
We never see the light of this from the kid.
Never.
This is one way in which McCarthy has revised Melville.
So this is one of those observations I'm going to sort of put up on the shelf.
What does it mean that this is the way he revised Melville?
This is one of the questions that my two lectures together,
we'll answer.
What does that revision mean?
Another specific scene in which McCarthy is revising Melville comes when
Toadvine almost kills the judge.
Do you remember the scene?
The judge has been dangling.
The little Indian boy on his knee,
the man around the campfire are delighted.
They laugh in the morning.
The judge has killed the boy and scalped it and is wiping his hands on his pants
and Toadvine puts his revolver to the judge's head and the judge judge says,
shoot that thing or put it away and Toadvine puts it away.
This is the direct echo of a moment when Starbuck stands outside.
Ahab's cabin Ahab's maniacal quest for the whale has been made apparent to the
whole ship.
Starbuck that wise and deliberative man understands that the fate of the whole
ship is now.
Ben Has now been recruited to Ahab's maniacal cause he knows that if he takes
the Moscot and shoots Ahab in his bed,
he will save the whole ship of men.
He does not do it.
Okay,
so both Toadvine and Starbuck are presented with a moral problem.
Do you murder the leader of an immoral ill fated violent quest?
Both men decide not to.
This is a scene I'll come back to next time on Wednesday and I'll have more to
say about it.
But for now,
one thing that we can say about it is,
once again,
the lack of interiority for these characters makes a crucial difference.
It's a crucial point of revision.
Starbuck we know is deliberative.
We know he is a wise man.
He gives counsel to Ahab over the whole course of the novel to abandon his quest
to go home to his wife at the very end of the novel and a crucial moment.
Starbuck gives an impassioned plea to Ahab,
reminds him of his wife and child and says,
you know,
leave off chasing that whale.
Um,
let us live and go home.
We have no such history for Toadvine.
Well,
what do we know about Toadvine?
he wears a scapular of ears that he's cut off.
He has tattoos from his criminal past on his face.
Okay.
He wears the evidence of a criminal life,
not the furrowed brow of Starbucks.
Thought.
Yeah,
he is a very different kind of character.
And that leads us to wonder how we need to understand his failure to shoot the
judge.
Is it that moral complexity yields lack of decisiveness,
as we might say for Starbuck,
that moral complexity is presented as a kind of weakness or is that far too much
to say about Toadvine is turned vine or morally complex character?
Do we have any basis upon which to say such a thing?
So this is another kind of question we want to ask now I'm going to move to my
second in line here and that's paradise lost.
Mccarthy rings the changes on the great voices of American literature,
but also of of world literature in English.
Uh,
you were talking about the Iliad and the epic tradition.
Um,
in this case he is entering the great a realm of poetry.
Now he gives a specific revision of paradise lost in,
uh,
in blood meridian.
If you recall,
how many of you have taken a Milton class or have read Milton in class?
Okay.
Good number of you.
So,
uh,
probably a bunch of you realize this when the judge makes gunpowder.
Do you remember this scene?
The men are out of gunpowder.
They find the judge in the desert.
They're being hounded by the Indians.
They've been chasing all this time.
They're at their mercy.
They know they're going to be massacred.
They find the judge sitting on a rock in the middle of the desert.
Who knows how he got there.
Glanton takes him up,
he rides with them and he takes them to a volcanic cone,
a dead cone.
And there he instructs them how to make gunpowder.
He takes brimstone from the room of the cone.
He mixes it with charcoal and other things.
And then he has them piss on it.
And from this,
he makes gunpowder and they use that gunpowder to defeat the Indians who come
after them.
Well,
this is taken directly from paradise lost.
Um,
Satan instructs his fiends and how,
how to make gun powder.
And I'm going to read you a little bit from books.
Six of paradise lost.
So the fees are down in hell,
strategizing somewhat in despair over their chances against God's angels.
The fallen angels are standing around Satan in they're taking turns making
speeches and they've just heard a speech from a fallen angel who says,
you know,
we really need a better weapon otherwise we're never going to win this war.
And uh,
here's what Satan has to has to say.
We're to,
we look composed.
Satan replied,
not uninvented that which thou right beliefs.
So main to our success I bring which of us who beholds the bright surface of
this ether is mold,
where on we stand,
this continent of spacious heaven adorned with plant fruit,
flower,
ambrosial gems and gold who's ISO superficially surveys.
These things as not to mind from whence they grow.
Deep underground materials,
dark and crude of spiritists and fiery spume till touched with Heaven's Ray and
tempered.
They shoot forth.
So beauteous opening to the ambient light,
these in their Dark Nativity,
the deep shall yield us pregnant with infernal flame,
which into hollow engines long and round,
thick round at the other bore with a touch of fire,
dilated and infuriate.
That's very much a McCarthy word in fury.
It infuriated shall send forth from far with thundering noise.
Among our foes,
such implements of mischief as shell dashed to pieces and overwhelm.
Whatever stands a verse that they shall fear.
We have disarmed the thunderer of his only dreaded bolt.
So they're Satan saying,
look at the world.
You look at all these plants,
the chemicals we need are in this earth.
So this is what the judge says.
Um,
for his part in like circumstance.
This is on one 29 one 30 and this remember is told by Tobin,
the ex priest,
okay.
In
all of this time,
as they were riding across the plane without gun gunpowder,
nor this time,
the judge had spoke hardly a word.
So dawn,
we were on the edge of avast.
Malpais and his honor takes up a position on some lava rocks there and he
commences to give us an address.
See,
there's that same structural position the judge occupies,
the place that Satan does in paradise lost and gives a speech.
It was like a sermon,
but it was no such sermon as any man of us had ever heard before.
Beyond the Malpais Hayes was a volcanic peak.
And in the sunrise it was many colors.
And there was dark little birds crossing down the wind and the wind was flapping
the judges,
old Benjamin about him.
And he pointed to that stark and solitary mountain and delivered himself of an
oration to what end?
I know,
not then or now.
And he concluded with the telling us that our mother earth was,
as he said,
was round like an egg and contained all good things within her.
Then he turned and led the horse.
He had been riding across that terrain of black and glassy slag,
treacherous to man and beast alike and us behind him,
like the disciples of a new faith.
So the oration urging them to see in the earth,
all the things they need exactly out of paradise lost.
And then a little further down the page,
you see that,
um,
Tobin speculates about the,
the um,
the volcanic terrain,
they're crossing a four a where for OT man knows lies the locality of hell.
Even speculate that this is where hell's entrance might be.
So what does more Carthy do when he invites us to see the judge as the parallel
of Satan?
I think this is one of the most powerful illusions in driving readings of this
novel.
Lots of readers have taken judge Holden as heroic evil on the model of Milton.
Satan.
Remember the famous problem about paradise lost is that here was Milton writing
it to justify the ways of God to men justifying how good God was.
And yet Satan is this incredibly compelling character.
Milton Rights Satan to be irresistible.
And in particular he is rhetorical,
Lee,
incredibly gifted.
And so he makes all these wonderful speeches that Milton rights for him that we
get to listen to.
So McCarthy sets up a similar problem in blood meridian.
Here's the judge.
He has this compelling language that we want to listen to.
It's very sonorous.
There's that debt to the oral tradition.
Yeah.
And yet he is this incredibly evil,
ma'am.
So there's a problem here of moral valence.
Can we condemn or does the book condemn this figure?
It's the problem in paradise lost.
It's the problem also in blood meridian.
If you find the via violence in blood meridian,
simply gratuitous,
then you've answered that in a certain way by saying no,
the characters not so compelling that I can put up with the graphic
representation of violence.
It doesn't make it worth it,
but there's another school of thought that says the aesthetics of the violence,
the aesthetics of the judge do make it worth it.
So that is a kind of debt.
The other way this sheds light on the novel is to say that the novel is
concerned like Paradise lost with the great cosmic structures of the world.
Now this is another element too of its use of the Bible,
and we'll talk about that in a minute,
but it gives for the novel certain kind of weight.
It makes us read it.
Looking for those big cosmic structures and statements about those big cosmic
structures,
it lends it wait,
unleavened by the kinds of delightful playfulness that we see from Ishmael.
Melville's full of the Bible and full of pretentiousness too,
but always Ishmael's voice is they're charming us.
What we have here instead is sheer pretentiousness.
Some say pretentiousness weighing on every sentence.
The Ao allusions to paradise lost are part of that pretentiousness.
Yeah,
no.
Let me move to something smaller.
Moving a little later in the poetic tradition,
Wordsworth in the opening lines of this novel,
we see the line,
yeah.
On page three,
all history present in that visit,
the face of the kid,
the child,
the father of the man,
that phrase,
the child,
the father of the man comes from a short little poem by William Wordsworth.
It's called my heart leaps up when I behold
my heart leaps up when I behold a rainbow in the sky.
So it was when my life began.
So it is now,
I am a man.
So be it.
When I grow shall grow old or let me die.
The child is the father of the man and I could wish my days to be bound each to
each by natural piety.
So this is a lovely little s little snippet of a poem.
The point of it is to say that the child delighted by the Rainbow
gives you the man delighted by the Rainbow.
And he says,
uh,
let me die if I'm no longer delighted if I get to be so old that that child like
delight in the rainbow was gone.
The rainbow comes freighted with its own biblical,
uh,
literary history.
That is,
it's the sign of God's promise to the world,
to humankind that God will no longer send a flood to wipe out the human race as
he did in the days of Noah.
So it is a hopeful sign for the fate of humankind and it reflects well on God's
intentions towards us.
Mccarthy's child,
father of the man is a very different sort.
Just read that sentence right prior to the Ellucian,
he can neither read nor write and in him broods already a taste for mindless
violence.
What McCarthy announces here in his revision of Wordsworth is that although to
invoke Milton is already to project us into the realm of romantic figures,
he is rejecting the later romanticism of the early 19th century,
which found in humankind,
especially in the child as the epitome of pure humankind,
a kind of great hopefulness.
This is not what McCarthy sees and humankind.
This is not what the kid gives to us.
Even though even though we are told a little later on,
on page four,
the child's face is curiously untouched behind the scars,
the eyes oddly innocent.
What does that innocence mean?
Is it here an innocence like Wordsworth's child who can be hold the rainbow with
joy and a pure relation to the world and to a caring God?
Is it that kind of innocence?
Is that the innocent simply of not knowing something?
Is it an absence of guilt?
Is that what the innocence is?
These are questions.
Again,
I'm going to put up on the side what is the quality of the kids' innocence.
This is something I'm going to answer on Wednesday,
but I want you to think about it.
The allusion to Wordsworth causes us to ask that kind of question.
The revision tells us we are in a much darker world.
Now.
I'm actually going to skip over some of the biblical illusion and and trust you
to read in the first couple of pages.
Just in that first section.
I'd like you to reread it and think about how the Bible is woven in there.
You see lots of garden of Eden imagery there.
Um,
you see,
uh,
a parasite,
the image of the murdered father.
There's an echo there of Canaan evil,
even though they are brothers.
There's a sense that this is a world in which violence and murder has already
entered.
So you can think about that.
I want to go now to my last,
um,
in the pile of books.
This is an historical source called my confession and it is by a man named
Samuel Chamberlain.
Chamberlain fought for the u s in the Mexican war and after the war was over,
he joined up with the Glanton gain.
The Glanton gang is a historical fact as far as we know.
It was a gang of scalp hunters that operated around the border right after the
Mexican war in the 1840s and 50s.
Sam Chamberlain,
I want to show you,
he was quite a remarkable guy.
He was from Boston,
born in New Hampshire.
Um,
grew up in Boston at 16.
He left Boston and went out west,
taking a sort of circuitous route.
He went to find his fortune and to find adventure,
but he also
went with a box of paints and he produced these amazing watercolors everywhere
he went and he wrote a,
this testimony of his,
his adventures called my confession.
It reads like a picaresque.
It's full of,
uh,
his own heroism.
All the senior Rita's that he romances all the great battles he fights in,
but he really gives us an amazing,
um,
set of,
of paintings.
You can just see these,
I'm going to show you a couple.
Hello.
Well,
I'm waiting for this to come up.
I'm going to show you something you can't see on this website.
This is the Texas state historical society where these documents are kept.
Um,
the pages are written.
I don't know if you can see this.
This is a reproduction.
See,
he writes in this gorgeous hand and he embellishes all the pages with little
drawings and this is hundreds of pages long with hundreds of watercolors in it.
My bet is that Mccarthy actually saw this manuscript in the Texas state
historical society.
That's where he lives.
That's where he was living when he wrote this book.
Um,
and it just is amazingly visual and gorgeous.
He ended up making three copies of this with all its paintings.
When he got back to New England,
he married and he had three daughters,
which he named after various senior reaches that he had romanced and he made a
copy of,
um,
of the,
of my confession for each.
So there are three of them.
One is at Annapolis,
one is at the Texas state historical society.
And I think one is with the family.
All right,
so this isn't giving me the paintings that I want and I'm going to,
these are two that I took up.
Um,
this one on the right.
Well,
we'll do the little one on the left.
The one on the left is his drawing of the Grand Canyon and he claims that it was
the first ever painting of the Grand Canyon.
I think this is probably false.
Um,
that's them,
uh,
crossing through the game.
This is judge Holden here.
Discoursing on evolution in a very judge Holden Li Wei.
So we actually hear about this,
a sermon on evolution in the novel.
Well,
here it is in Chamberlain's confession.
Now I want to read to you a little bit from the confession.
The second in command now left in charge of the camp was a man of gigantic size
who rejoiced in the name of Holden called Judge Holden of Texas.
Who or what he was,
no one knew,
but a more cool blooded villain never went on home.
He stood six foot six in his moccasins,
had a large,
fleshy frame,
adult tallow,
colored face,
destitute of hair,
and all expression always cool and collected.
But when a quarrel took place and bloodshed,
his hog like eyes would gleam with a solid ferocity worthy of the countenance of
a themed.
I'm gonna skip a little bit.
Um,
terrible stories were circulated in camp of horrid crimes committed by him when
bearing another name and the Cherokee nation and Texas.
And before we love Fronterra is a little girl of 10 years,
was found in the shop role foul.
He violated and murdered the mark of a huge hand on her little throat.
Pointed out him as the ravager as no other man had such a hand.
But though all suspected no one charged him with a crime.
Yeah,
he was by far the best educated man in northern Mexico.
He conversed with all in their own language,
spoke in several Indian lingos out of Fandango,
would take the harp or guitar from the hands of the musicians and charm all with
his wonderful performance out waltz,
any Poblano of the ball plum center with rife rifle or revolver at Deering
horseman acquainted with the nature of all the strange plants and their
botanical names.
Great in geology and mineralogy with all an errant coward,
but not that he possessed enough courage to fight Indians and Mexicans or anyone
where he had the advantage in strength,
skill and weapons,
but where the combat would be equal,
he would avoid it if possible.
I hated him at first sight and he knew it.
Yeah,
the intellectual beast saw fit to patronize me in the most insulting manner,
lecturing me on the immorality of my conduct in drinking and gambling.
This was shortly after the murder of the MOOC Chacha and when I made an angry
reply,
he said,
Come Jack,
don't bear ill.
We'll shake hands and makeup.
I replied,
no,
I thank you.
Your hand is too large and powerful.
It leaves its mark hold and gave me a look out from his cold,
cruel eyes and quietly said,
you are there.
Are You well,
look out where my hand may squeeze the life out of you yet my young Bantam,
I felt like trying my revolver on his huge carcass,
but prudence forbid bringing matters to a deadly issue at present.
There's that same Toadvine Starbuck moment.
It's right in my confession as is that particular strange description of judge
Holden as huge and hairless.
Now in the 19th century,
hairless just meant that he didn't have a beard.
But Mccarthy takes that and makes it into this really freakish character.
It's almost like he's a giant infant.
What does it mean that McCarthy gets the most powerful character in the novel,
so directly from this source?
That's one question.
Second question is,
what does it mean that he's actually taking and historical fact the Glanton gang
and their adventures and using these as the kernel of his novel?
When as my little pile of books here has demonstrated
he's totally absorbed in the novels relationship to literary history.
So what's he doing by doubling the literary history with an American history,
he's pursuing two sets of links back through time.
One in the realm of art,
one in the realm of history.
What's the relationship between the two?
When I first read this,
I will say I was extremely surprised.
Are you surprised too,
to see that it takes so directly from chamberlains manuscript?
The problem is the problem of originality.
This is a problem that I think Mccarthy's quotation that I wrote up on the board
points towards.
Okay.
The ugly fact is
that books are made out of books.
Why is that an ugly fact?
What's ugly about that?
The novel depends for its life on the novels that have been written.
Is it ugly?
Because it calls into question the very principle of originality.
This is what someone,
a reader like Harold bloom might say,
Harold Bloom argues that,
uh,
it is the anxiety of influence that shapes many writers in the tradition as they
take on the great writers of the past.
They feel that they are ever be deleted,
that there is no room yet in the world to push the art form further.
Is that why it's an ugly fact?
Is its ugliness or the way that word is used in this quotation?
Is it registering McCarthy's about his own belatedness can he really be
original?
Okay.
Can he really answer the poor tentious cosmic aura that he invokes over and over
again in the very style of this novel,
the style keeps telling you come and look for a deeper meaning.
I want to point out one last thing for you.
Uh,
since I do have just the couple minutes that I will need.
This is on four and five,
um,
at the top of four.
As the kid moves from Tennessee down to New Orleans and then out to the west,
he moves through the south.
He sees
blacks in the fields,
lank and stooped their fingers.
Spider,
like among the bowls of cotton,
a shadowed agony in the garden.
There's some of that Eden imagery I was gonna point out to you at more length
against the suns declining figures moving in the slower dusk across a paper
skyline.
The landscape itself is already an artifact.
It's paper.
It's as if it's of Mccarthy's own construction.
But if you look just across the page on five,
this is a tiny thing and probably it didn't register to you at all.
A week on,
he's on the move.
Again,
a few dollars in his purse that he's earned walking the sand roads of the
southern night alone.
His hands balled in the cotton pockets of his cheap coat.
Do you notice the way the words are repeating their spider like among the bowls
of cotton,
his hands balled in the cotton pockets of his coat.
It's a tiny little thing.
I would argue,
however,
that what we're seeing here is the way the very style and tone perpetuates
itself out of itself.
So I want to add a final layer in my excavation of illusion and hearsay that
he's out alluding to himself,
that there is a constant re layering
that takes the language and the repetitiousness of that language builds within
the text.
Okay.
There is a lot of anxiety about origin right here in these couple pages were
told only now is it as he goes to Texas,
only now is the child finally divested of all he has been
and note at the beginning that he is and his folk are known for hewers of wood
and drawers of water.
These are the traditional adjectives given to the sons of ham,
the hewers of wood and drawers of water,
Hams,
crime against his father.
Noah was that he saw his father,
no one naked in his tent.
Noah planted a vineyard,
got drunk and I guess he was naked in his tech tanned while he was passed out.
Ham happened to peep in and saw his father naked.
His two brothers covered the father.
The two brothers are there.
Blessed Ham is cursed.
Why?
Why is this a a curse worthy action?
Why is this a curse word?
The mistake.
I think it's because in seeing the father naked,
you see the mystery of your origin
and so the kid is likened to someone cursed for looking upon their origin.
There's a sense in which he can almost understand it.
This is meant to be mystery and yet by looking somehow he is closer to it then
he should be.
The problem for the kid is to divest himself of origin to forget it.
So if ham is cursed because he saw his origin,
the kids curse lies in part in the divestiture of all origin.
He forgets it.
It's not that he sees it,
he forgets it
and then you can get a sentence like this.
His origins are become remote as is his destiny and not again in all the world's
turning will there be terrains so wild and barbarous to try whether the stuff of
creation may be shaped to man's will or whether his own heart is not another
kind of clay.
Will you to read that sentence several times before Wednesday and ask yourself
if you can figure out what it means fully.
All of it.
Parts of it are more clear than others.
Think about the balance between the rhythm of that sentence and it's content.
The tone,
what its tone says to you,
what it's diction says to you,
and what the sentence itself actually says to you.
So that's what I'd like you to think about.
And on Wednesday I'm going to take this discussion about illusion and I'm going
to sort of ball it up and it'll become part of another argument.
And that'll stem from one tiny detail I'm going to take out of the novel.
So that's where I'm going.